pendant toute cette insurrection les
femmes ont joué un grand rôle on parle
de l'umih nation madame claire bouchons
qu'il du quartier l'éosine quitté du
quartier pourquoi les femmes jouent un
très bon temps gilbert pago dans son
livre d'un mal bien sophie d'expliquer
bien mais ceci s'explique très bien dans
la configuration graphique bayisa y ces
femmes qu'est ce qu'elle faisait celle
qui ramenait vers les beaux les produits
de la t1 que l'on m'a hulot compagnon
évidemment cultivé et en allant se
déplaçant de lemon est en contact un
club il a suffisamment les boutiques les
petits producteurs et aussi les
acheteurs ceux du bourg et celle qui
fait circuler l'information d'ailleurs
le petit souci qu'ils avaient fait faire
appel au tribunal ebay ce sont les
femmes qui ramasse et ses soucis
affaissé centimes qu'on appelait des
goûts de l'époque et qui ramassait des
sous et qui ramenait le club du bon pour
évidemment là pour la paix le tribunal
vous demander la libération le l'appel
du procès de l'ubs est donc ces femmes
ont joué un rôle extraordinaire dans
l'ordre d'assurer ctions on voit bien
qu'elle est à la tête de sélection
elles ont été condamnées l'odm en une la
société golden aubagne d'un est morte à
30 ans madeleine clem qui avaient
chahuté n'a jamais tari t bouchons avec
haïti etc si vous venez à m'arrêter et
ces femmes si blake était quand même je
dirais qu'on me dit maintenant poto
mitan de cette vie économique et cette
vie culturelle et de communication et l
enjeu déterminant d'acteurs elsa et et
vous avez vu lors des procès elles ont
été condamnées du moment d'accord il ya
des condamnations de femmes et ensuite
du bail